the 2002 remake of the original Resident
Evil successfully revived a beloved if
flawed game and later that year
Capcom used the same creative techniques
to craft a prequel Resident Evil zero
which has now been dusted off and
refinished for modern platforms zero
pairs Rebecca chambers of the special
forces unit stars with Billy Cohen a
slick military prisoner who is on the
run the two meet on a train that's
overrun with zombies but the duo
eventually make their way to the mansion
like training facility of the evil
umbrella corporation they need to escape
but a series of monsters and puzzles
stand in their way
like numerous other Resident Evil games
zero challenges you to carry just enough
supplies to defend yourself from zombies
and heal your wounds while also leaving
space for key items that are used to
solve the game's many puzzles with only
enough space to carry some of your
findings you spend a lot of time looking
at your inventory debating what to keep
and what to leave behind when compared
to earlier games in the series zero
makes this process easier by not only
affording you two characters but also by
allowing you to leave items anywhere you
wish as opposed to specifically
designated storage chests as seen in the
previous games still zeros limited
health and weapon resources provide
gripping tension as you navigate
dangerous uncharted territory
there are times too when you are
separated from your partner making the
job all the more difficult
in these moments zero instills even more
anxiety with heightened fear induced
senses you also pay more attention to
your environment which is often
beautifully rendered and presented
through dramatic camera angles
controlling your characters in a fixed
camera system can be tricky on occasion
especially when transitioning from one
shot to the next accidentally diverting
onto a new trajectory for all its faults
by designer otherwise zero still
scratches the quintessential Resident
Evil itch you hardly ever feel safe and
when working on difficult puzzles you
have to force yourself into dire
situations not knowing you'll find a
solution to your quandary or even come
out alive on the other side instilling
tension is a commendable feat especially
given that zero relies on tricks that
are over a decade old however there are
times when the game manages to throw
whatever immersion you are experiencing
out the window zero can be too silly for
its own good
it's hard to tell whether you should
laugh or jeer when the camera cuts from
the Train to an opera singing
villian atop a distant Mountain or when
Billy utters one of his many 80s b-movie
grade one-liners so you seem to know me
been fantasizing about me have you more
than most games in the series zero ramps
up the challenge in a clever way by
starting you on a train to Train it's a
linear environment with two levels on
just a handful of enemies and puzzles
allowing you to come to grips with the
controls and the types of challenges
that lie ahead you do fall into a
routine towards the end of the game but
this version of zero offers a palate
cleanser after the fact that instantly
renews your infatuation Westerman the
unlockable Wesker mode is by every
metric totally absurd it replaces Billy
with Wesker the series iconic
behind-the-scenes villain he possesses
superpowers including the ability to
endlessly release bursts of energy that
decapitate nearby enemies he can also
sprint incredibly fast knocking over
enemies in his path and with him at your
disposal zero becomes a game about speed
and force rather than one about
desperation and careful play and it's
difficult not to laugh specifically when
Wesker opens his mouth and Billy's voice
comes out zero bears the hallmarks that
made the original Resident Evil
enjoyable at a glance it looks
impressive with some expertly composed
shots and highly detailed environments
some issues from the original persist
reminding you how far controls and games
have come since 2002 but they are
temporary frustrations that fade once
you find your footing and continue your
journey you may attire up the formula by
the end of the game but with Wesker at
your fingertips don't be surprised if
you find yourself eager to sprint
through zombies and decapitate them with
blasts of energy it's just crazy enough
to work
you